everybody this is the askgaryvee show
and we know this is my show my show
you got your perspective everybody and
welcome to don't put that in your mouth
my name is Marc source ASIMO and today
we have a very special guest mr. Gary
Vaynerchuk thank you so much for being
here Gary thanks for having really
appreciated funfact real quick I'm
willing to put anything in my mouth
this is just super importantly weird
about me I understand that everyone's
gonna make jokes but like I eat
everything including weird things like
like I'm willing to eat non-food things
this has been like a big joke amongst my
friends for a long time so like I have
no idea how people do on this show but
this is a piece of cake alright well we
don't have any pieces of cake here today
but we do some other stuff Gary if you
don't mind giving the people the three
people at home who don't know who you
are a quick 10-second background of
yourself you know I'm an entrepreneur
that's caught a lot of attention in the
digital age by being someone who a lot
of people follow on Twitter back in 2007
YouTube lately Instagram but I've built
businesses first e-commerce website in
America two hundred million dollar
advertising agency early investment
Facebook Twitter her things like that so
make a lot of content for free five
meter Times bestselling books Dyer Jets
fan that's me and you built a wine
business from the ground up well you
took over your family's wine business
yes it was on the ground and you yeah I
mean my dad did an incredible job he
came to America with no language no
money and built a 3.8 million dollar a
year business that I grew to a 60
million dollar business quickly which
was the first way people knew of me and
then later you know and so I left that
business I built it for my family so I
didn't leave with any dollars but made
some good investments in Facebook and
Twitter which gave me an opportunity to
start vaynermedia perfect and now this
is not our first collaboration together
I don't know if you remember this Gary
give me two videos together back in 2013
we had this little vine video together
oh yes did holy [ __ ]
forgot about that one in front of a
audience at Barnes and Noble
oh I'm sure never forgot that moment
alright so today we're going to be
pairing wine with three foods and by
that I mean we're going to be pairing
cat wine wine made specifically for cats
with three different food flavored candy
canes let's go let's get it started so
do you prefer
Gary red or white white so today you'll
be drinking the meow slang wine and I'll
be trying out the pur getting thee so
this is literally made for cats it is
made for cats it is made with salmon oil
catnip and a few other Wow oh yeah the
stiffy stuff i am literally about to
have cat wine this is wine made for cats
out of a plastic bottle Oh glass Jesus
with some candy canes okay so let's uh
let's give it a baseline taste here
cheers to good health that is atrocious
doesn't really taste like much no just
tastes like water and like sewer I was
expecting a little bit more salmon from
the salmon oil to pop up yeah show her
that I'm forcing sewer maybe it is
fortunate that we didn't taste the
salmon all right so let's uh looks first
let's try here I'll try pairing it with
the mac and cheese candy canes that I'm
excited about for you thank you so much
wow that really tastes like mac and
cheese doesn't it delicious
I kind of like it yeah not bad really
good so how do you think this goes with
your album your cat wine cat wine
enhances everything it does it really
does oh I wasn't leaving d-roc but thank
you get out of here that's pretty good
is this something like if you saw this
on a shelf would you reach for this
again just by itself yeah I could I
would I like this um there's a lot of
people watching who if they were in my
position would want to ask you a billion
questions and I don't want to have your
time here and not sort of take advantage
of your expertise no problem so four
questions for you as we go along
let's go ahead first question what is
the largest mammal you are those oyster
will get late very subtle no sorry sir
what is the largest mammal what is the
largest mammal you think you could knock
out with a single punch this question
comes from reddit right it's not for you
nice I got it I know the classic nature
of this question
um a pony okay I'm into that answer pony
it is next we have some rotisserie
chicken candy Wow these did you find
these online yeah makes sense coming
episodes of this have you done this is
episode 31 and how many guests have you
had it's always a guest always this
smells atrocious Wow tastes exactly like
it it's surprisingly OnPoint remember
Kenny Rogers Roasters I do I think
that's that's what the world is missing
these days fast casual chains by country
music Carl
and what if Garth Brooks opened up the
restaurant what kind of restaurant Lenny
open Brad Paisley's you know pumpkins
pies Brad Paisley if you're listening
alright how does this pair terrible
really bad it's kind of like a
Thanksgiving in my house I don't know
why is so bad well it's got some a
little bit of catnip in it so it does
your funeral
I'm feeling a little bit excited yeah
I'm tracked it to your code right now
all right
yes next question yes toilet paper over
or under on the roll over over over that
settles the debate once and for all
folks I know you're all you out there
wandering Gary is a toilet paper
preference there you go
what do you think Scott to actually you
know I don't wanna die god I don't wanna
get into politics here get into politics
Scott toilet paper what's with the
people who choose to use that like I
understand it's cheap but it's like
sandpaper yeah I'm I'm weird on this so
I don't even know if it's good or bad
like I'm so not fancy when it comes to
toilet paper like I am I'm like I've
used like I'll use a tissue like I don't
even understand the difference
piece of toilet paper and like what
about a leaf would you use the leaf
I would use anything all right I'd use
my hand and just wash it real fast I'll
be pretender than that
you know like if I'm being honest like
like I'm very wheat like I said this
earlier about food like I'm not what is
it called when you're like oh yeah go to
everything what would that be what's the
word of that I don't know I'm the yeah
what was that yeah I'm the reverse of
squeamish okay
nothing makes me squeamish oh yeah I
know honestly I'm very good like that
honestly here we have like I don't even
wash my hands
globally like that's just a macro
statement so like you're in a public
place restaurant I go pee don't wash my
hands walk out no problem I don't wash
my hands often so I don't think I get
sick I have that Sam I give the same
reason subway i touch everything I was a
bike nut this delicious this is delish
like this one this is tough I love it I
like by the way this would really [ __ ]
with people cuz I love oysters lips
tastes like oysters it's not as bad it's
bad you know what's funny all these
clams yeah right yeah they're called
clam became good wine it's funny it's
basically water yeah yep still it I
don't like it um Gary on an average day
how many pigeons do you think you could
reasonably carry physically on me sure
that's the question right
pigeons hanging hanging up average day
at one time lore over death over the
whole day how many pigeons can I hold in
a day 17 seconds like 190 hundred
nineteen all right people get your
calculators out is that math
you have any any final thoughts on on
the the pairings of these wines and
candy canes III don't really know what
to make of it I was expecting the candy
cane company deserves a ton of credit
because the flavor profiles they're
using on their syrups or sugars or
whatever you know colorings or whatever
pom point tastes exactly like all three
as far as the wiser the cat wine was
really bad yeah I don't like it I feel
uncomfortable about it my favorite was
the clams well in there that I thought
were oysters and the wine company's
defenses wasn't exactly made for us
fair enough the mac and cheese would be
number two the rotisserie chicken number
you were really into those clams oh yeah
well as a consolation prize you can keep
the rest of them thank you mother
absolutely
one last question yes you could buy the
Jets right now yes with the one
stipulation that you had to wear Jordans
every single day for the rest of your
life would you do it
that's a great question bro that's our
that is a very well executed question
for me of somebody who understands me
not yet really really I'd wait interest
I think I can buy the Jets without
compromising okay that yeah I think if
you asked me that question when I'm 63
and I don't feel like I'm in striking
distance yes I just don't think I'd have
to do it now
fair enough and I feel like that's you
on things that you don't want to
compromise you try to wait until last
breath but I do think I would compromise
him yet I do I think at 69 74 if I
didn't see my ability to get there and
you were some weird [ __ ] genie with
cat wine and you know clam canes and
said bro I can really do this you can
own the Jets tomorrow but you gotta wear
Jordans I would do it all right but not
at 43 years old thinking I'm putting all
the pieces together properly for the
future fair enough thank you so much
Gary thanks for having me guys
final yeah words almost everybody who's
gonna watch this is unfortunately living
their lives based on somebody else's
opinions and that leads to extraordinary
unhappiness and we need to start making
being a millionaire not the ambition but
being a happy person the ambition and
I'm really I really believe that that's
about to happen and I want to be one of
the people that drives that conversation
amongst the hundred thousands of other
people that need to do it for it
actually to become real boy do I want to
eliminate judgment everybody here is
judging people we judge so much and now
with the way modern technology works
it's so easy to judge at scale with so
little context so little less judgment
and a little more empathy
[Music]